Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel me and my family we're spending
the week traveling around Alaska fishing
and camping we're gonna be dropped off
on remote Alaskan Rivers cooking what we
catch exploring beautiful locations
eating amazing food and having a great
time as a family
[Music]
hi good morning pleasure nice to meet
you Luke this is Tom and Nate hi guys
thanks Scott
the Silver's in good man there's a few
they're more and more every day but I
hear the Chums and pinks are hot
and single
so this is the kind of spot we're
looking for you can see how silty the
main channel is and how clear it is here
the fish come out of the sill to kind of
clean their gills and rest and you'll
get piles of salmon in here
[Music]
yeah well there we go there goes a ride
it's on us now let me grab the gear
let's go set up the tent and everything
me and the boys did this about two three
years ago and had an absolute ball did a
video on it I'll put a link to that
video in the description look at this
isn't this just a gorgeous spot to fish
now it's also a very popular spot you
can see there's a bunch of fishing
guides right there at the mouth and
almost all the fishing charters leave
early in the morning so probably here in
the next hour or so all of those
Charters will be done and then we'll
have this place to ourselves got me you
excited to catching fish yeah
longer
got a nice pink fly under a bobber
[Music]
oh he barely came off we'll get you
another one
I think you got a silver buddy yes yeah
we'll keep them
hold that up can we get a picture there
you go we need a Stringer
all right there we go you can have that
one if it bites hold on Nathan just
leave it be unless there's a fish on it
this water is like 38 40 degrees so
that'll keep the salmon nice and cool
hey yo it's a joke get your net low
there you go scoop them okay keep them
in the water so that right there is a
Chum Salmon it's the second largest
salmon you can see here he's got some
wounds probably from a seal got these
vertical stripes on them that's his
spawning colors they go from Silver to
turning this color when they get ready
to spawn oh
[Music]
they're five species of salmon here in
Alaska and that's probably the least
popular one to eat that's why they call
them chum salmon or dog salmon because
they're good for Chum or feeding to your
dogs and if you're gonna eat a Chum
Salmon you eat them when they're silver
not when they're that color
oh there you go there you go
[Music]
you want that one yep there's a fish on
there
see their food
there we go big old male pink salmon
they also call them humpies for obvious
reasons
this is a pink salmon they call them
pink salmon because their meat is really
pink you can see here he's got kind of
this gray stripe down his side and he's
got these big spots on his tail you
could eat this one it's not bad but
they're not as good as silver so we're
gonna let them go
chum salmon right there
there you go
[Music]
another nice job of salmon
well the salmon fishing kind of Ebbs and
flows as the schools of fish come up the
river one thing's kind of slow down
that's a good time to set up the tent
and get lunch out
Tommy you hungry
[Music]
you're Nathan come here
oops
you got Dijon mustard a spicy honey red
peppers salami ham muenster cheese gouda
that's a good sandwich
lemon cookies or Oreos oh just take one
just take one
found these big chunks of coal here on
the beach
gonna burn those up
oh
here's a lot of Fire Starting okay got
ourselves some Tinder here this is the
inner bark of a cottonwood tree that's
take this bit of cotton ball wrap it
around a stick it'll make like a little
torch
now put it underneath it
oh
yeah we got a Burly today
all right
another nice chump salmon
there you go get it back in there there
you go there he goes
well that's a keeper
oh that was a sockeye salmon
nice little humpy
a fish but I'm getting hungry I think
it's time to cook up that salmon
the seagulls took your fish
the seagulls took your fish took the
whole entire thing
oh let's go is there anything left no no
I'm sorry Nathan wait
do you hey
Nathan is really hating seagulls
isn't this our fish
I think the seagull got his eyeball oh
yeah they pecked a little hole in it but
I think they didn't get it
you feel a little better
yeah
we still hate them on principle oh
Tommy's got a fish
the seagulls stole our salmon but I
think they dropped it when they saw
Nathan coming wise move on the part of
this Eagle Tommy hooked the fish and
Nathan Landed It All by yourselves
nice little pig salmon
put a little coarse salt on him
a lot of butter right there
so I got that salmon stuffed with butter
and brown sugar seasoned with salt and
wrapped in tin foil
do you guys want salmon or hot dogs
well let's cut you some hot dog sticks
all right you got some hot dog sticks
I'm sitting here cooking and the boys
are down there and Tom's hooking fish
and Nathan's netting them for him those
boys are growing up so fast
there you go fresh salmon blueberries
and sweet cornbread
I love the flavor of blueberries and
salmon
well we've caught a lot of fish we've
got a lot of food in US and we're just
kind of relaxing and the boys are just
hanging out and we're having a good time
kind of my favorite part of the campouts
with everything just kind of gets
low-key
he wants to take off all your dirty
clothes and start getting your air
mattresses pumped up okay buds
[Music]
well good morning guys salmon fishing is
best early in the morning so it's about
a quarter to six
nice little chump salmon to wake me up
nice little pink salmon there
look at that that's a little silver
look he took it right in the corner of
the mouth you see Silver's when they
start to turn their spawning colors they
turn all red sockeyes get a green head
and a red body that's cool usually this
place is crawling with Silvers but it's
a little early in the run so we're just
getting the little guys first
there we go there's our cooler
all right this is starting to click
three species of salmon and three casts
foreign
there you go nice feisty pink
there we go
I actually designed this fishing rod
it's made from carbon fiber it's a
catfishing cart Maglite series by
whisker Seeker
love this fishing rod
man that thing hit
oh this is a nice one
that is a nice male silver starting to
take his spawning colors
look at that size comparison
all right
beautiful chump salmon
oh I had a silver ticket right at my
feet
oh beautiful silver that's my three for
the day
I'll let you guys catch them Tom you
want to catching fish
you go get one you get one
beautiful silver
I call this scrambled French toast what
happens when you forget to bring your
bowl to make French toasted you want
some maple syrup on there yes
[Music]
I like it
oh that was delicious
if you've ever want to come up to Alaska
and have a big salmon fishing Adventure
this is the cheapest way to do it if you
want you can take one of their guided
Charters to learn exactly how to do what
they're doing get some confidence
catching salmon and then you can come
out and do the drop-off service and do
it yourself
are you tired I'm so tired
that is then you're gonna
you guys are ever in talking to Alaska
want to do this too make sure you check
out Phantom try River Charters I'll put
a link in the video description below
all right I'll see you go
day three
all right so we're heading off on a
three-day camping trip with the family
but before we go we've got to stop and
get Japanese food you know because it's
camping they also have a Falafel truck
all right guys he wants a soda chocolate
oh nice
um
Japanese octopus balls it's like an
unsweetened pancake batter with a chunk
of octopus inside you like that
the cucumber and pineapple
[Music]
that's a lemon pistachio cake
that's a falafel
why would you not like this
now we got some food in us we're gonna
keep heading down the road
so we're gonna try to do some salmon
fishing and salmon fishing is not
complicated it's all about timing so
let's see if we're in the right place
the right time dozens of them right
there
every one of these salmon are about to
die they're all heading Upstream to lay
their eggs and as soon as they do then
they die
even though there's hundreds and
hundreds of pink salmon here they're
near the end of their life and they're
not in a feeding mood you're really just
harassing them into eating like why
would you not have a drop no thanks
anyway I'm fine
there we go that's a pink salmon
your Tom you want to give it a go yeah
yeah there you go keep that Rod tip up
the males and the females start out
slender and silver when they're in the
ocean and then when they get close to
spawn they look like this
they're noodling them
[Music]
love you too bye
hi Mom
hi
there you guys so this week we're doing
a big family campout it's kind of a
tradition once a year my parents and
siblings we all get together go camping
and you guys are
[Music]
um
David are you going swimming yes awesome
me and my boys caught some huge lean Cod
down in Dutch Harbor so I brought some
of the flays and we're gonna make a
curry out of those
all right
the hard way when I had a yeah
I have
maybe do you have fun in the lake
you want the carrots too bad
okay got some coconut milk
got some ginger slices lime leaves I got
my Ploy curry paste here
I think you're just oh here's the lean
Cod
good
me and Becca learned how to make this in
Hawaii we had a tie Shaft come to our
condo and teach us it was really fun
there we go a red Thai coconut curry
with lean Cod
Ed
there we go look at that
here
what do you think Dan you like it yeah
it's good it was really good
sweet not too spicy what did you think
did you like the curry no you didn't
have any did you you just worked
we're gonna do a s'more bar
e
we got marshmallows filled with
chocolate and marshmallows filled with
salted caramel and once you've roasted
your marshmallow we got various toppings
you can dip it in crunch up graham
crackers peanuts coconut shavings
sprinkles chocolate syrup and caramel
I'm gonna make a couple for Mama now
[Music]
cracker crumbs yes
that's really good my goodness oh that
looks incredible thank you
there you go
right right
well it's getting late I think it's time
to clean up don't want to attract bears
that's nice
sister of the king and that's why she
walked out I love that movie yeah you
planning hits home all right I think
it's time to start getting kids ready
for bed
[Music]
good
there we go got all the beds set up
most of us are going to be sleeping in
there and Tom and my nephew are going to
be sleeping over there
all right Jake you all tucked in
Nathan
you warm well a bit too you're a bit too
warm
all right okay all right
you having a good day babe good
what do you sleep well I slept
comfortably that's very diplomatic
oh
it hey Rebecca there is now a campfire
it is safe to get up
all right who wants hot chocolate
all right
there we go we got a little raspberry
turnovers and we got some chocolate
croissants too
there's hot water in there
chocolate croissant in hot chocolate
Berry Parisian
we've got the small affordable and so we
did I wasn't the ones
you know I was always
you like that babe is it good love it
get a no
all right go catch some fish Tommy oh
yeah there's the fish jumping right down
there
yeah
no Tommy guys you want some ice cream
you guys do any good you got one yay Dad
and Tom are having a great time
got to get a ham pie for Becca
oh okay will you tell me what you want
thank you
pick your ice cream Calvin yes very nice
they're Marion Berry and Melanie the
railroads
Becca and some of the other ladies went
painting I'm gonna go check on her see
how she's doing okay
I'll go see what I can do
foreign
okay yeah we're gonna do a little bit of
prosciutto
and uh white cheddar there
you can't go camping in Alaska without
imported cheeses and meats
is your idea of a good campout
great time thanks to you
stuff makes great fire starter darling
that's handsome I didn't finish but it
was fun yeah the rain kind of came in
and kicked you out didn't it yeah since
the kids didn't eat lunch do you want me
to just make an early dinner sounds good
to me
got the leftover bacon grease here
[Music]
we got a bunch of figs
little tomato paste and diced tomatoes
got everything
it's a non bread here
serve it up Dan hey Dan
good enough that is so much more here
you go
there's Vapor cuts
how many times you like it babe oh good
because there's a lot of it to eat
abortion control is the problem for
Megan do you like the food loved it went
down fast thank you
no no it's a rice booty Becca did you
want me to take you out on the kayak all
right let's do it
foreign
[Music]
used to take me and my brother fishing
here when we were younger Blake's got a
lot of trout and golden fit in it
sounds fun yeah you enjoyed that you did
hey
[Music]
more family showed up we got mac and
cheese or some weird Moroccan dishes can
I mix the two together yes
oh yeah
it's like a wig
they've got mariachi music
what are you guys up to Tommy going
fishing did you just make a fishing rod
yeah we were fishing in my uh Rod broke
he's got got swivels on it for eyelets
Dan you're the boss man well we're gonna
see if we can catch anything
where are you
yeah
do you like the rice booty I love it
Tommy come here did you guys catch
anything no did you have fun yeah are
you cold
okay there's you good
oh good I'm glad you're here
all right it's getting late people it's
time to get these kids to bed
[Music]
you want me love you guys go to sleep
well good morning guys so whiny
how you doing
well I can hear my dad getting up making
breakfast I think I think that's a good
sign up there it sounds really rainy out
here I think we've got slugs climbing on
the tent
oh that looks pretty good dad it looks
even tastier when I don't have to cook
it dude
typical Alaskan weather you got to get
out there even if it's raining because
the summers are so short I was gonna say
actually yeah
okay we got chocolate pancakes now baby
there you go
but he was afraid of my womanly ways
well despite the lovely weather we've
got to pack up and go home
[Music]
all right got the tents hung up well
it's been a wet but fun adventure and I
hope you guys enjoyed watching this as
much as we enjoyed filming it if you
guys want to see more Adventures from
the outdoor Boys YouTube channel make
sure to click subscribe thanks for
watching if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning hit that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching